Avengers infinity war might have pleased
audiences everywhere but if you're a fan
of The Incredible Hulk the film may have
been a bit frustrating to watch why well
we may as well get this big green
spoiler out of the way right now in the
beginning the Green Giant who stands a
brutal beating by Thanos before being
whisked away to Earth by Heimdall and
that's the last time you see him in his
full green glory Bruce Banner tries and
fails several times to get his other
half to come out and play but the Hulk
refuses to emerge so why is the Hulk
being shy all of a sudden the most
obvious answer is that he simply doesn't
want to enjoy a second round against the
mad Titan but there might be more to it
than just that let's take a look at why
the other guy doesn't want to play the
hero game anymore father of mine one
regrettable aspect of Bruce banners
portrayal in the MCU is that as popular
as banners I'm always angry line from
Avengers has become the movies have
never explored exactly why that rage is
always with him so it's possible that
directors Joe and Anthony Russo are
using Thanos to finally give us a
glimpse of that story in the 1985 comic
Incredible Hulk issue 312 longtime hulk
writer bill Mantlo
wrote one of Bruce banners most
memorable and influential stories most
of the tale is a flashback to banners
younger days we learn that both Bruce
and his mother Rebecca endured extreme
emotional and physical abuse at the
hands of Bruce's father Brian Banner
Brian eventually ends his wife's life
for trying to escape from him montolo
essentially told readers of the gamma
bomb blast from 1962 s Incredible Hulk
issue one didn't create the Hulk the
trauma Bruce and jawed created the Hulk
the gamma blast to set him free it's
possible that what's stopping the hope
from emerging in infinity war isn't that
the beating he took from Thanos scared
him but that it really Candace childhood
trauma in fact this could be why a
certain bizarre scene was deleted from
thor ragnarok in the scene of banner
expresses regrets at missing his
father's death because he was too busy
working
because focus but that would be a
strange thing to say since not only did
the comic book banner have no fluffy
feelings for his father but it was
eventually revealed that Bruce Banner
actually killed his father
if the infinity war filmmakers plan to
use Hulk's shyness as a way to introduce
the abuse backstory the conversation
from the deleted scene would've made
sense a Hulk humiliated maybe The Hulk
isn't scared
the Hulk isn't traumatized maybe he's
just embarrassed the Hulk has never
experienced a kind of defeat Thanos
handed him in the opening of Avengers
infinity war and the green Goliath it
doesn't just have the intelligence of a
toddler he has the emotional maturity of
one to the beating he took may have
destroyed his confidence the Hulk
doesn't have any particular skills like
his teammates instead the Hulk's sole
purpose is to beat people up if he can't
do that then in his mind how could he be
anything but worthless it's worth
remembering that not only is banner
around other Avengers each time he tries
to change into the Hulk in infinity war
but there's a specific avenger he's
being reminded of Tony Stark Tony's the
only guy other than fallows who's
managed to lock the Hulk out the first
time Banner tries to change in infinity
war Tony's right there urging him to
Hulk out a second time a draw in the
battle in Wakanda
Tony's nowhere to be found but Banner is
inside the Hulkbuster armor inside the
suit that not only gave the Hulk one of
his only defeats but was created solely
for the purpose of beating up the Hulk
it's possible that it was the wrong time
to remind the green Goliath of that
third Rock from the Sun but maybe the
reason Hulk refuses to emerge may not
have anything to do with Panos at all
maybe a sea earth that's the problem
Thor Loki Valkyrie and even banner may
have been fine with leaving Sekar and
thor ragnarok
but the Hulk didn't have much of a say
in the matter during that first
one-on-one tire log scene together Hulk
even told Thor plainly he had no
intention of returning to Earth why on
soccer Hulk was treated better than had
ever been no one even knew about banner
the people of saccade didn't run
screaming from him for smashing his
enemies they cheered them they had
parades for him why would he want to
leave so perhaps after he sent to New
York Hulk decides he just doesn't want
to fight to protect the place that seems
to hate him so much the blame game we've
already talked about the Hulk's fear and
humiliation but it's also possible
Hulk's refusal to fight was about guilt
and friendship right after the Hulk is
defeated by Thanos Heimdall uses his
last few breaths to transport hog to
earth so he can warn them that means the
first time Banner tries to Hulk out as
far as a Hulk knows he's the only
survivor of the Asgardian refugee ship
and that Thor Valkyrie and everyone else
is dead considering Thorin hog formed a
bond that during Ragnarok perhaps his
belief that he wasn't strong enough to
save his friend would be crushing
if so the revelation of Thor's
really alive during the Battle of
Wakanda could be a huge relief and might
help clear the way of hopes arrival and
Avengers 4 so you can do this again
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you're left a
[Music]